my name is wen dekotora and I am a poet
a pen Africanist and a freedom fighter I
was 23 years old when I first heard
about reproductive justice I was working
at women with a vision where I learned
that reproductive justice was defined by
sister song as one a woman's right to
decide if and when she will have a baby
and the conditions under which she will
give birth to a woman's right to decide
if she will not have a baby and her
options for preventing or ending a
pregnancy and three a woman's right to
parent the children that she already has
in safe and healthy environments without
fear of violence from individuals or the
government I've always wanted to be a
mother growing up I heard all about the
joys of motherhood I used to dream of
watching my womb weave wonder into this
world see I knew I was young but I
figured it couldn't hurt to start
planning for something so big so early
but now I'm 26 years old and I don't
know if I have what it takes to stomach
motherhood in this country see over the
years America has taught me more about
parenting than any book on the subject
it has taught me how some women give
birth to babies and others to suspects
it has taught me that this body will
birth kin who are more likely to be held
in prison cells than to hold college
degrees there is something about being
black in America that has made
motherhood seem complicated seem like I
don't know what to do to raise my kids
right and keep them alive do I tell my
son not to steal because it is wrong or
because they will use it to justify his
death do I tell him that even if he pays
for his skittles and sweet tea they will
still be those who will watch him and
see a criminal before a child who will
call the police and not wait for them to
come do I even want the police to come
too many Shaun bells go off in my head
when I consider calling 911 not take it
for Oscar granted that they will not
come
kill my son so he may have gotten rid of
the nooses but I still consider it
lynching when they murder black boys and
leave their bodies for four hours in the
Sun as a historical reminder that there
is something about being black in
America there's made motherhood sound
like morning sound like one morning I
could wake up and see my son as a repeat
of last week's story sound like I could
wake up and realize the death of my
daughter wouldn't even be newsworthy so
you can't tell me that Sandra bland is
the only black woman whose violence
deserve more than our silence what about
our other dark-skinned daughters in
distress whose deaths we have yet to
remember what about our children whose
lives don't fit neatly between the lives
of your genders see apparently nothing
is a great protector if you come out of
a body that looks like this see there is
something about being black in America
there's made motherhood sound like
something I'm not sure I look forward to
I've written too many poems about dead
black children to be naive about the
fact that there could one day be a poem
written about my kids but I do not want
to be a mother who gave birth to poems I
do not want a stanza for a son nor a
line for a little girl nor a footnote
for a child who doesn't fit into this
world no I do not want children who will
live forever in the pages of poetry yet
can't seem to outlive me
I was invited to the TED Women's
Conference to perform a poem but for me
poetry is not about art and performance
it is a form of protest yesterday during
rehearsal I was told that there had been
two to three recent TED talks about
black lives matter that maybe I should
cut down my TED talk
so that could just be about reproductive
justice but that poem and this talk is
fundamentally about my inability to
separate the two I was 21 years
I was 21 years old when Trayvon Martin
was murdered Trayvon Martin a 17 year
old black boy a black child reminded me
reminded us how little this nation
actually values black life the hashtag
black lives matter became the most
recognized call for black people and our
children to live in safe environments
and healthy communities without fear
from violence from individuals or the
state or government months later when
George Zimmerman was not held
responsible for murdering Trayvon Martin
I heard Sybrina Fulton Trayvon Martin's
mother speak her testimony so deeply
impacted me that I found myself
constantly asking what would it mean to
mother in the United States of America
in this skin what does motherhood really
mean when for so many who look like me
it is synonymous with mourning without
realizing it I had begun to link the
reproductive justice framework and the
movement for black lives as I learned
more about reproductive justice at women
with a vision and as I continued to be
active in the movement for black lives I
found myself wanting others to see and
feel these similarities I found myself
asking whose job is it in times like
this to connect ideas realities and
people I want to dedicate this talk in
that poem to Constance Malcolm she is
the mother of Ramarley Graham who was
another black child who was murdered
before their time she reminded me once
over dinner as I was struggling to write
that poem that it is the artists job to
unearth stories that people tried to
bury with shovels of complacency in time
recently Toni Morrison wrote in times of
dread artists must never choose to
remain silent there is no time for
self-pity no room for fear yesterday
during rehearsal when I was told that I
should May
we cut the blacklivesmatter portion from
my talk I found myself fearful for a
moment fearful that again our stories
were being denied the very stages they
deserve to be told on and then I
remembered the words I had just spoken
in times of dread artists must never
choose to remain silent
there is no time for self-pity
there is no time for self-pity and no
room for fear and I have made my choice
and I am always choosing thank you
[Applause]